[Applause]
[Music]
as you guys know I am the greatest human
being on the whole planet
Felix you're always so hot oh no no I'm
not and today it's time for me to
finally prove just how superior I am in
every single field I'm gonna do what's
called a human benchmark where I will
test my abilities and prove once and for
all that I am worthy of a hundred
million subscribers god damn it why am I
doing this
alright you guys should try this as well
and see if you get a better score than
me and if you don't it's actually you
won't you just can't my reaction time
you saw how fast I was aim hundred
percent accuracy chimp test what even is
named visual Oh Oh No
okay confession I'm really bad alright
well let's try it anyway I kind of want
to see all right reaction time test your
visual reflexes the average reaction
time is around to 45 to 40 milliseconds
cringe alright so when the red box turns
green click as quickly as you can
alright alright watch this watch this
here we go
no come on that's pathetic I can do
better
[Music]
yeah come on under 200 I got to do under
200 come on that was terrible
god damn it well there it is smashed it
Oh
100 200 yeah here we go again
[Music]
[Laughter]
I got a do that eh I got a do that again
alright what'd I get
that's right above average suck it
average you suck yeah Oh reactions time
go out almost average under 200 thank
you very much
don't even talk to me yeah this this
doesn't count this doesn't count the
first tried doesn't yeah alright let's
get into do-it-yourself posters score
and then we can talk
alright aim training I got 100% accuracy
let's go 30 target as quick as I can
boom boom boom this is fun to watch see
that accuracy whoo all right what do we
got what do we got
boom average can suck it suck it a
bridge or look up far away I am from you
you're so bad that bridge people hmm
I'm better than average just like my
penis
sorry about that info hell yeah hell
yeah I told you bro I try to tell you oh
god here comes the great chimp test are
you smarter than a chimpanzee be honest
I don't think I have God am it
I have spit on my wall
Oh smarter than the monkey Oh
big brain oh my brain there's no blood
in there Papa Papa up come on come on
smarter than a chimp what do I got to do
what I got to do I'll do anything are
you smarter than a chimp click that
requires in order according to their
numbers click the squares I couldn't
even read what'd I just say
the test will be get progressively
harder ok bing bang bong boom easy yeah
bing bang boom boom boom is this even a
challenge cringe you just gotta say bing
bang boom boom bing bang boom boom Bing
bong
yeah oh it's getting more difficult bing
bang Bing bong Bing bong bong yeah
Oh God Oh goddamn chimpanzees the damn
champion sees only cheetah Nutella so
that they die from palm oil shortages ok
bing bang bong Bing oh god this is a
tough pattern ok I see the first one and
I gotta go reverse triangle ok reverse
triangle down does that make sense
reverse triangle down
which one do I start with yeah reverse
triangle stupid chimp you would never
think of the reverse triangle I actually
thought I got a rock first I can't got
that it's stressing me out a little bit
and I don't do well on the stress in the
moon all right let me think okay so one
two how do I count to four okay yeah
easy
screw you chimp more like him that is
not an insult or is it I don't know oh
god oh god oh oh no uh-huh
okay I'm gonna divide this into two
increments okay three increments Rick
I'll do the flip and then okay I'll do
the program and then I do the break and
then I I have already forgot it was like
this prayer prayer prayer prayer the
prayer works
all right I'm giving you guys helpful
tips all right first you got a good and
then okay my memory is so bad by the way
it's absolutely terrible I'm trying to
learn another language right now
Japanese and I absolutely suck at it my
chair can read thing a one thing one
time and she's like yeah I remember that
I study it I'm like that's not how my I
have to read it at least three times
then maybe it's this I know people are
cringing I don't care I'm getting the
score that I want but the bonus come on
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes I'm
already way above average
yes I we're going for that we're going
for the big boys boys big boys boys
big boys boys I'm a big boy boy I
probably take this like a hundred
percent more seriously than anyone this
is some people are smart some people
just try really hard okay that's me
don't people have to try hard shut up
got it no no I had it this is so much
harder to remember
[Music]
yes suck it chimpanzees you got nothing
on me chimpanzees more of the apes or
whether Bad Kitty movies called ain't
not not hat been I cancel chimpanzees
alright come on
fourteen the numbers they all make sense
what do they mean I don't know but they
make sense I see a pattern one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen boom bada bing
bada boom you're here I'm here mother
we're gonna get 18 I don't even give a
[ __ ] I got it yes I feel like this data
just reflects the people that really try
it's like I don't really care I'll just
try thirteen is here fortune is here
fifteen is there nice
I'm trying way too hard chimpanzees were
able to remember nine digits ninety
percent of the time wow so most people
are at the same level of a chimp huh
how does that feel not me I'm twice with
the chimp I gotta get to it eighteen
come on this one this one this one this
one this one I did it hey I'm proud of
myself I kind of just want to end it cuz
I'm getting guy this is getting dragged
out what am I on seventeen but this is
taking forever so I'm just gonna go out
could have gotten to max score alright
alright so not a chimp feels good I'm
glad we got that over with visual memory
remember and increasingly like let's do
something different let's do hearing
okay
high frequency son will play okay you
guys tell me I think you guys can
technically play along on this tell me
when you hear the sound
Meredith did you hear before or after I
mean obviously not after what I get yeah
better ears than average let me try that
again so you guys can try it again and
I'll you just let me know when you hear
it I'll say stop when I hear but I won't
click stop okay
there ah I'm sorry okay I can't stand it
so most people hear it around 1800 yeah
that makes sense
God Dan alright I'm always thought my
hearing was bad but I guess it's okay is
that what that means
alright typing I'm not really used to
this keyboard
Oh God once upon a time there was an old
mother pig who had three little pigs and
not enough to food to feed them so when
they were old enough okay here we go
Oh God ole mother pig who had three
little pigs and not enough food to feed
them so when they were old enough she
sent them out in to the world to seek
their fortunes the first little pig was
very lazy he didn't want to work at all
and he built his house ah oh ah no no
damn was that good almost 100 words per
minute
100 100 percent accuracy how is that
good or bad I can't tell let's see oh
damn I came into this like a joke I'm so
good I feel pretty confident maybe I'm
not so dumb after all this has nothing
to do with intelligence but hey I'll
take it IQ tests next maybe oh god we
only have memory back left and I'm so
bad at memory okay mo what what happened
at 13 14 okay most people can do 9 all
right if I can be most people that's
really the goal here okay so remember
the the pattern yeah I remembered the
pattern alright easy so the average is 9
it's it's very easy in the beginning it
must be like a big learning curve after
9 see I'm already struggling okay come
on Oh God
did I do it I'm missing one no I got it
okay I feel like that was an easy one
I'm missing something
oh shoot ah I really only just looked at
this I did it what no what happened oh
that's easy
Oh God
[ __ ] 13 all right I'll take it
I kind of messed up I can definitely do
better but who cares at this point
verbal memory yeah my cell was
complaints I forget stuff so here we go
so I'm supposed to click new if it's a
new word and scene if I've already seen
it Flavius gambling scabbing seen it
delicacies seen it seen it new champion
pepper tree
sulfa weird those seen it seen it seen
it
measurably seen it drone unfailingly
disguised fireclay reuler atrocity seen
it seen it seen it seen it
Oh have I seen that seen it select or
seen it seen it reuler seen it forrestal
seen it knocked em ballistic oh god we
had a similar one but I think it's new
yes
no it wasn't atrocity seen it jeno types
seen it see oh that was terrible
god i'm see i'm not good at these god
dammit top-40 told you yeah memory i
can't do it
same with numbers man same with numbers
this is just pain from now on what was
the number i legit was it a night I
didn't look yeah god how do you guys
remember E this is really fun four four
five four okay yeah for my boy see I
really struggle the numbers like
whenever I have to remember passcodes
36.5 it's so tough 36 so five four six
three seventeen but I said it wrong in
my head that I got to do that again come
on I said it wrong in my head it doesn't
count if I say it wrong in my head I
can't really talk and and do this at the
same time these are really weird cuz I
really focus on one bit and I for some
reason if I focus on one the other one
we'll just stick like the last one I see
well there's be in my quicker memory see
I didn't even try to remember the last
numbers but they just stuck somehow it's
really weird
actually now I did the opposite that was
way easier I should memorize the last
part and then just look at one part and
type it in as fast as I can okay five
one three nine seven five one three nine
seven five one three nine seven five one
three nine seven five one three nine
three nine seven see that works that's
so cheating what is the average on this
oh god I'm
I shouldn't be bragging most people can
do this ok 9 4 6 4 6 1 9 4 6 4 6 1 9 4 6
4 6 1 9 4 6 4 6 1 9 4 6 4 6 1 9 4 6 4 6
I beat the average hey you ok so most
people really struggle around 10 and 11
let's see if this strategy works ok 40
41 40 40 1 3 6 9 40 40 1 3 6 9 40 40 1 3
6 9 40 40 1 3 6 9 40 40 I think I didn't
get it I didn't look at the first
numbers good enough yeah there you go
I'm not I'm not good at numbers clearly
my strategy didn't even even work all
right
above-average brain oh now I finally
proven once and for all everyone calling
me dumb in let's place when I don't see
an item or and I forget simple pass
codes you have every right to criticize
me if you pose that you have better
scores stinky brainer that's it for me
this episode hope this was entertaining
if you enjoyed smash like become member
we now have big announcement if you made
it this far for whatever reason watching
a Swedish man indulge in his own
abilities we now have official PewDiePie
minecraft servers right now only
creative is available but survival is
coming and events and stuff like that so
if you want to join join tier membership
all the money goes to charity it's for a
good cause play some minecraft I'm gonna
be making a video as well so make
something cool and creative and then
I'll react to it I think that could be
really fun everyone gets their own
little space in the server it's pretty
cool but yeah that's it see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]
it's time to race what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
hope T is coming to Nintendo's wait and
remember it has a very big TV pre-order
promotion heavy
[Music]
jmes checkbook birthday girl ran away